in the lobby of Ramsey solutions if John
and Erin are with us hey guys how are ya
welcome welcome where are you guys from
Charleston South Carolina
oh nice town very fun welcome to
Nashville thank you good to have you
here
so you're here to do your debt-free
screen we are I love it how much have
you paid off of nothing too specific but
we paid off three hundred ten thousand
five hundred seventy one dollars and
fifty eight cents I love it that's a lot
how long did this take just under 20
months okay there's a story here what's
your household income range during that
time um we started at 120,000 went down
to about 95 and then went back up to 120
okay very cool okay so what did you sell
we did sell our house oh okay those
numbers don't work otherwise all right
so what did the house sell for well so
we had about seventy thousand dollars of
debt besides the house right yeah what
did the house sell for three three
hundred thousand 305 303 303 sorry
okay so 303 of the three eleven though I
mean you use some of that equity or
whatever came out of that and you could
use that to become debt-free right house
and everything yeah so now where are you
living
so we had the opportunity to do
apartment life so we're a Karass team at
a community in Charleston so like
you'reyou're so we live in an apartment
you have furnished housing not furnished
but it's substantially reduced rent
because of because of one of your career
choices and because of the service that
we provide to the community so we we
welcome new residents and we throw
events for them and stuff
yeah oh yeah Nate all right that's cool
yeah and so how much is your rent it's I
think it just changed to it's just
around a thousand yeah okay yeah it
would be if you weren't doing this um 20
you've arrived
oh wow Wow okay so it's nice play it's
nice it is very nice place okay so
substantial so that came into the
picture is that what caused you to sell
the house or you sold the house then you
found
well so what caused us to sell the house
was so we had a kitchen flood and you
know it destroyed all the floors and the
island and stuff and so after everything
had been ripped up and torn out we just
kind of took a walk around our
neighborhood to get a breath of fresh
air and we saw some townhomes mm-hmm and
got to thinking what would it look like
if we sold if we sold our house and we
moved into something around this range
you know twenty first twenty percent
down 15-year fixed and it was like half
of what we were paying for a mortgage so
that got the got that wheels turn in on
thinking about selling our house because
we were just gonna rent it while we did
this the cares program and so as we got
to thinking about it more and more which
by the way that that was the catapult us
listing our house and then the next week
we actually got the call to be placed at
an apartment community all your cares oh
is God confirming this is what I want
you to do so yeah so that that the lower
payment really is what got you goddess
thinking yeah that's an interesting
journey that you've been through so what
started the whole process of getting out
of that 20 months ago so I really wanted
to stay home with our babies I was
pregnant with our first child Connor and
I just you know it leading up to it I
was like oh yeah I'll just we'll just
make it work I'll just come home and as
I started back to work it was it was
like there's no way I'm gonna be able to
quit we have so much so many payments
going out we're just not going to make
ends meet if I quit and so the debt is
or the borrower's slave to the lender
really rang true to me the the chains
holding me back from being able to stay
at home I felt that wait so you were you
guys the change so you saw us somewhere
or so yeah so so I had a hard time
getting John on board I had read the
Total Money Makeover
and I don't like reading books so I was
having a real hard time I was doing the
budget and it didn't matter we would
always go over because he wasn't on
board so I was listening to the
broadcast online and you ran a special
it was like the 20th anniversary for FPU
you know and it was like the first 90
callers that wanted to be a Financial
Peace University leader they would get
the kit for free so I talked to him
about it he was like yeah that's awesome
let's do that
and so a couple weeks later I call back
and the guy was like you know I heard
the commercial again on online and the
guy was like well the promotions over
it's been over I'm surprised you heard
that but we'll go ahead and honor it so
he got a signed up to be a few
coordinators so it's totally a god thing
and so yeah so we led the class and kind
of went through it ourselves for the
first time I understood what's going on
but it was I loved it I loved I'm big
visual it really helped me especially
since I never read books right okay good
for you very fun cool so that got the
whole conversation going and then you
guys are working the budget now the
house comes into play and you just blew
up everything we did we didn't blew up
everything yeah and now you're home
because that's the change in the end
come down and then back up I know he had
a he decided to do a career change
and it didn't work out and so he went
back to what he was doing but because he
had left he didn't have the full-time
commitment you know the full-time hours
and so that was a little shaky in the
middle of it but then he went ahead and
made a sacrifice and took a position
that worked was overnight basically so
so we're just still I'll be able to stay
home hopefully soon we're just getting a
few more things ironed out okay very
good
I love it so the third one's on the way
yeah third one yay good for you that's
fun and the other twos names and ages
Conner is two and a half and Madison is
about 14 months okay and they're with
you are they gonna do a debt free scream
with you
we've been practicing all right very
cool well you guys are incredible how
old are you - I'm 33 and I'm 28 yeah I
think very good I think so good
Oh good-looking family very nice all
right it's John and Erin Conor and
Madison Charleston South Carolina
311,000 paid off in 20 months making 120
down to 80 back up to 120 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one well done good good good job
beautiful family very well done you guys
very proud of it hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income earner $500,000
in the car